okay welcome to this live stream we are
looking at visualization features for
version 12.1 a wolf language and that
looks exciting okay so what are we
looking at here first so so as a
preamble vector plot is one of the few
visualization functions where you're
unlikely to be successful the first time
you use it
okay so we've greatly improved the
automation and the structure of how you
specify things it was a super
complicated way and when you iterate it
you were unless you really committed you
were unlikely to be successful in
tweaking the options and now we are also
using back to plot in a variety of other
ways so there's a complex vector plot
then there's a Geo vector plot and so
that problem became more urgent so this
is a basically a dramatic overhaul of
the vector plotting functions to one
that uses glyphs not stream plot stream
plot is just fine but vector plot right
so the issue is with a stream plot
there's no ambiguity in where the stream
lines are if you can compute them you
can draw them whereas in a vector plot
there's the question of your
representing this vector field using
samples of the vector field and showing
arrows at certain points right so let me
describe some of the aesthetic
challenges that were there if you you
know that we've addressed one problem
was that we were mapping the norm of
vectors so you're plotting a vector
field and a norm the length of the
vector the length of the arrow yep okay
that didn't give us a lot of bandwidth
to express different sizes so you would
have vector field vanishing and to show
no yeah I understand or it crashes into
each other right but we bound that
anyway but but yes you would get that
unless we've done that but what the
effect of that is that that the biggest
one is gonna fit so it drives to all the
ones to zero so that's that's you do we
can get seen at many times yes yeah it's
it's horrible right so we get so the
first mitigation is to get better
dynamic range by using nonlinear
transformations
scale and other things but that still
doesn't solve the problem it mitigates
it but it doesn't solve it now the other
thing that that we've gone with now so
that's there that improvement is there
and it's much easier to specify how you
sort of scale those magnitudes but the
default setting we don't scale them and
that's usually called the direction
field we map the magnitude onto color
because we actually can assume color and
we've been using color more now so
that's the default setting and it's as
easy flip if you want to go with
magnitudes instead or though we're
changing the default is what you're
saying we're changing the default and
there are some new option names so
they're much easier option settings and
not five you have somebody from design
here I mean we have Tim from design
let's just can't enjoin us just in here
he's not but we can grab him
could you and then I wouldn't mind
asking Jeremy to join us if he can for a
minute I mean just like to go over these
these some final aesthetics here I mean
it looks pretty nice there there it's
now I'm super proud of this function now
it's now a function that's successful at
first try and it's solid you know
there's a final little tweaks but I'm
just gonna complain about some things do
with these colors okay so those rings
the colors are wrong are wrong oh well
okay then that's that
that's a simple ok can you send me
what's right if you scroll down a little
bit further there's examples that are
right and I'm not well I'm not happy
with the new ones either
so see Justin can you send Tim shuttle
Bauer the Twitter that the twitch the
zoom info as well please yeah
and we want Jeremy Davis to yes okay
okay
so if you go down to the section
probably after director points
uh yeah just right so vector range
clipping style this should all be right
and so this one is I think I went back
you know too far the other way and so I
was using a dark slightly darker version
of let's wait for a design folk to be
here so that we have the bottom line is
that you want a sense of scale for that
if it because it may Mac we map norm or
magnitude on to that color so you want
that intuitive feel of scale is from
small to large right um okay
designed for cure or not this should be
coming yeah I just sent them a message
okay all right okay let's keep going on
just me understanding okay so first
thing is flipping magnitude becomes
color then um so this vector points
thing that was an existing option is
that correct there was an existing
option and it was you know something
like vector points goes to ten or twenty
or twenty close a analog of plot points
and that's giving us the the gratit the
the the I don't know what you call it
you know that the density of sample it
gives you the grid yeah by the way can I
just make a random graphics complaint
why is contour plots so unbelievably a
memory intensive and is that fixable I'm
not sure off the top of my head I think
it goes through rounds of subdivision
though which might contribute to it
could you take a look because it's
killing things on the cloud very
regularly contra plotters yeah contour
plot um okay so okay so vector points
now has some named options that
represent different strategies for where
to put the where to root the vectors so
to speak oh right
and we're proposing switching the
hexagonal by default okay instead of a
square grid sounds highly sensible to me
hexagons have more room to maneuver so
to speak well and it allows our vectors
to be a little bit longer by default
Yeah right right
um okay vector markers okay so that's
what to do whether to have an arrow or
something else right and that's all that
hasn't changed okay okay but that's just
showing off a couple of the algorithms
for selecting points
but so this business about arrow length
I mean we do have to have a version in
which arrow length does represent we do
yes yes okay we do so next section um
right so there's that vector fields you
know and you know evaluated in v12 and
it has a couple of poles and so
everything just vanishes right um okay
okay back to scaling is that a new thing
so Viktor scale is an old option that is
practically incomprehensible so put in
two new options and replaced its meaning
essentially so a vector scale is still
there a vector scale is gone
vector scale is still there but it will
you know the documented behaviors will
be something different
backward compatibility and if you look
at the source you can see the new sorry
of what if you go to source notebook you
can see what the new proposed is there's
a vector scale new notebook okay
so it goes from min to max and this is
how it does it is that right
if you what is it actually what is the
actual setting doesn't say what the
settings are reserved what you mean what
are the settings well where is the
setting with s 1 and s Max Factor this
is a new option vector sizes it says
given by vector sizes oh I see I see I
see I see I see
don't make st. paragraph you point it do
you know what's the owl or go back to
scale an ordinary plot is there some
other scale thingy look at the one than
your help browser
yeah window behind that one yeah yeah so
there's automatic large medium smells
I'm not asking that King I'm asking an
ordinary plot what is it I end the my
answer is there isn't one okay
and because if you look at it I just
think it's amazing little settings right
I think the name is awful okay I think
that this should be something like you
know vector scaling function or
something or scaling
yes well that was exactly what I
proposed so we went from Victor scale to
Victor scaling sorry - Victor scaling
function back to vector scale - vector
scaling back to vector scale okay um why
did you do that because we wanted to not
have this once sit out there you know
the only reason we had sort of this was
an old symbol we had obsolete it yes not
a terrible it's a terrible name anyway
we should just obsolete it okay in which
case I think Roger and I prefer vector
scaling I agree with that I think back
to scaling but given that they're a
bunch of string named cases is the right
thing okay um all right so should it be
vector sizes or vector sizing it's it
follows bubble sizes double sizes by the
way this whatever is happening with that
autocomplete is very very very weird you
see that thing bubbling just I'm glad
I'm not the only person who thinks okay
could we could we report that for me to
report that please no III will report it
okay well it's a little
because bubble sizes is a lot more of
exercise I could live with I mean you
know honestly this could have been
bubble sizing yes I don't know I would
prefer vector sizing because I think
vector size is just so generic um and we
could even consider you know having
bubble sizing as an alternative and
eventually deprecating bubble sizes it's
not that important to come on well which
which one what are you proposing no no I
mean to change bubble sizes because you
have a sort of a different part of
speech preference ten years yes yes I
mean this is why sizing yeah why all
right okay vector size is fine I just
worry that exercise is gonna end up
getting we're gonna end up wanting to
use that for some other thing that is
more central aim or whatever probably
not okay fine okay let's take a look
here so vector aspect ratio what does
that mean so so that is you know
especially in the case where you're
drawing these glyphs it controls I get
it you know the space that the glyph is
drawn into which is always a rectangular
thing that's not necessarily aligned
with coordinate axes is that correct
okay okay let's talk about um guide
pages now have icons oh cool let me see
one of those
let me see another notebook cuz I forget
isn't that okay um but let's come back
to the question of color for these guys
here okay okay can you send me what you
think is the current color palette color
setup for these and then how do I
determine the color is it a color
function it is through an option called
vector color function
and they see that option here it hasn't
changed
it hasn't changed it was existing okay
to determine colors of field vectors
okay um okay but so previously that was
set to none or something is that right
right I think it's always been automatic
it's just automatic was nothing well
wait a minute vector plot is these are
the things being fed X Y V X V Y norm V
X V Y no it's that vector
function arrow name indexes into the
color data that's how they all have been
working yeah I understand
okay so so what did it do before what
about all the other functions that are
mentioned here like stream plots and
things I mean stream plots there's no
reason to color it right right but it's
automatic so it's will still not color
it okay okay so I mean you've you've
broken out into like not being in Kansas
anymore into color with all the complex
plot 3d and so on stuff which is the
first first cases where I think our
default plotting is color uses color and
a non-trivial way isn't that yeah a City
plot density plot does but it's a big
density plot could be a pure gray scale
although isn't it by default grayscale
pencil no it's no it's the same color
scheme as the rest of the plots okay I
mean I personally think we might want to
liven up a color scheme in general
sometime soon um
but okay can we please see what the
default colors that you're proposing
here are not easily what can't you to
show me your screen I can't generate
those three curt those three in the
default colors okay why not well I can
probably do two of them but we need to
see all three just let's see the
hexagonal case in um you know can you
just send me either a screenshot oh yeah
let me just get my build and figure and
maybe Tim can say what the what the
color what the default color function
actually is which field is that okay Tim
with us yeah I'm here I'm not sure I
didn't work on this so I'm not sure what
these are that's gonna you know wait
wait wait who did work on this I mean we
have we we are just now deriving sort of
the actual final color function okay
fine color functions yet
these ones but no no we did too right so
but we resilient other problems to solve
along the way okay okay fine
is there anything else then given that
we're looking I think this looks
beautiful but let let's maybe loop back
to the color function to go through some
of the other things we have to cover
during this meeting sure sounds fair so
yeah so next up there so dude this is a
big are we very happy about this because
now this part of the system we can be
proud of too and it will always work
which vector plots yeah I agree I think
it's very nice I mean III you know
listen I made vector plots
I mean I'll show you an example of a bad
example you want to see a bad example
from a long time ago
oh let's see your favorite bad example
no I mean but this is a bad example
probably made probably made with
packages I have no idea what when um
okay so here's an example of how well we
can even see this but this is an example
where this is a vector field right and I
think I mean this one you kind of could
see what's going on but it's very
annoying I mean this had to be tweaked a
lot to actually be able to see what's
going on right and presumably in your
proposal the vectors now the vectors
might get pretty random out here I mean
that's another issue the short vectors
may be pretty random looking right but
they're all equal lengths so if they're
random orientation it'll devolve into
noisy colors yeah but you will see that
this won't tell us there won't be colors
they'll be it'll all be the same color
they're all short right you want to go
with sort of different lengths then
they'll they'll have that characteristic
yes no no no I'm sorry I'm saying that
that in your model
I mean your thing here the lengths will
all be the same the lengths are just
determined by the unit vectors yes okay
so in this picture what you will see is
brighter colors here yeah there's
there's more velocity field right over
here what you will see is a bunch of
random direction things and this by the
way should inform the color function
because actually when the you know it
should gray down in the case where the
things are short because otherwise we're
gonna see as a jumble of crud there you
see what I'm saying
mmm right it's an argument to have the
colors get lighter or grayer as it goes
to you know zero in general by the time
it's very close to zero the unit vector
is going to be in totally random
direction well you're right so we need
sedan that we need to bench we need to
do experiments without before we know
okay so I'm predicting I think this is a
good case to look at cuz it's gonna come
up in a lot of CFD things where there's
a background field that's coast to zero
right
and where there's action somewhere right
are you gonna make sure that looks good
I think it can look good by having you
know even though these things are all
random directions it'll be sort of gray
out there right okay um and I think your
case here I think the case where you've
got I mean well you're feeling the same
thing in a dipole field which is what
you got here basically right the problem
of the dipole field the way the reason
you're kidding yourself here is because
you didn't do this wasn't you know this
is an exact function it's rather easy to
compute right whereas if if if at close
to zero field the thing is you know it's
it's I think you should get one which is
computer with numerical you know with
some numerical method so that the thing
gets a bunch of errors close to zero
field right yeah in fact in fact what I
would do is take the vector components
and give them random noise because
that's gonna randomize that you know
close to zero field it's gonna randomize
the direction this is okay okay so do we
want to look at anything else here
that's always gonna look at the guide
page did you send me that I sent you the
notebook of the guide pages
well for some reason that's not working
will it work in them and so each of
those sections is a link to Magnifico
page new I think these need to have I
think little bit more space yeah more
space tight slightly smaller icons they
are definitely more space here that's
not going to work I mean then you have
got to treat this slightly different way
think this is they show it to Jeremy
type situation okay I think these are
these need to go down by like 20 percent
in size relative to that font size I
don't know how the size is coded and I
also you need to check and let me try it
here okay that works nicely and they're
all vector graphics right there rpm geez
okay you should talk to in the world of
high DPI support you need to talk to
Jeremy to make sure that that's going to
work right
they are high DPI DPM geez okay fine
alright right then there's a few cases
where we haven't generated the icons yet
for some new functions okay okay cool um
Sandra's asking about the fluid dynamics
know that the the plate is moving but
filled us that that at infinity the the
fluid is stationary the spin there's a
CO moving frame with the plate um okay
great let's keep going here Geo density
plot do I need to look at that Joe
actually I haven't seen Joe Joe Conte
have I seen zero density plot is that in
no although no no it's not in twelve Oh
have I seen it before at all I don't
think so either I think that's
interesting so so like that's the
gridded population for the earth or
something something like that and the
examples especially for density we need
some better test data that they're for
examples I think there's a gridded
population for the earth and the data
repository interesting this looks really
weird I don't understand this so this is
this is kind of like this is a haze on
top of the base map yeah so they all
have kind of a an opacity because you
need to know you want to know where you
are
oh yeah I know but this one we're not
seeing any opacity - I don't see
anything yeah yeah think there is you
just aren't you know it just doesn't
show up well and that data is just
elevation which I get it I get it I get
it but I mean in in in so if I said so
let me just understand this so
presumably I can actually run this here
so if I say geo elation data of you know
Mount Everest let's say geo range um
five miles okay that should give me a
generation thing now oh boy that's a
disembodied quantity okay that's in this
UFO Zayin people right I mean if you
look at the Juno elevation data call in
the Geo density plot talks you'll see
that it is possible to get the non
disembodied data out of it
now I can see that right it's a mess
so this is something we need Hosea can
somebody see if we can find Hosea given
that we're about to talk we're now
talking about geo plots yeah I'll go
track them down okay um that doesn't
make a lot of sense to me that that's
not possible to bring that in there you
know because this is this is basically
painting data on a yeah something not
good about that now geo contour plots
obviously that would be the most natural
thing in the world to have as a G
relevant thing right rights and is it's
still a total mess to get it out for
that it's the same it's okay but so if I
say now geo contour plot of that percent
one it's just gonna go bonkers right
yeah so if I say contour that would be a
list contour plot correct AB percent one
okay I'm telling you contour plot it's
just the most you know horrible function
I really think you should look at
contour plot I think it's bad and that
column is matters pretty awful I think I
think the colors are uninspired and not
very clear that was a comment relevant
to Tim I think I suspect these colors
predate Tim know these are the V 10
colors so was involved in that well I
think we can modernize them I think we
can you know shop you know crisp on them
up um okay but but so these
- here is see this is a case where it's
like getting out of time series versus
getting out of table of values right
something like that yes uh Jose um we
are looking at geo elevation I know geo
density plot and realizing that geo
elevation data gives us something that
it's very hard to use in density plot so
I mean the issue is what is the analog
for ton of time series for geo data
Roger that will be for you
well we business would be field data so
there are two kinds you know and so the
original goal was to have something
called spatial data we're not working on
that now we work on a spatial point data
but this is not it this is this is a
field so that's it there's a value for
each point in space for the elevation of
Mount Everest okay I understand that but
so Michael sighs so what do what are the
attributes you want from such a data
object you want to be able to search and
pick things and look things up in but I
mean the point about a time series is
that there's associates raw
actual dates with values right yeah and
this is the same thing for a field I am
well and well geo field basically well
write any field but then the question is
what are the operations you want on it
you know I understand them that's what
do you like time series because you can
operate on it it's not just dead meat
yeah I understand I understand so the
issue here is that it's the result is
missing the coordinates right it's not
about interpolation so there is a third
argument in the elevation data that
allows you different types
what's the second argument second
argument is a type of elevation the
elevation with respect to the ellipsoid
the rest with respect to sea level etc
and the third and the
third argument allows for example to
return a geo position which would have a
coordinate for each value okay so I
think that's something where we'd say
automatic and then we'd say gee opus
quotes quotes chair position I think it
works both ways
we sang without coach okay and what does
that mean what is that blue thing you
mean it's just it has so many points
that it's just drawing all of that but
that seems like a bug I mean that's a
minor bug yeah it's you to very many
parts 200,000 points so now I'm not sure
that that's going to take the positions
but but that has all the values of the
coordinates okay but so so that's a geo
position I don't understand what the
structure of it is but this should
clearly work it's it's an array of
triples light long height I see
so if that worked if kilo contour plot
and geo density plot took those tripled
geo positions then this would at least
deal with this issue right Brett correct
which is what I'm not sure why it hasn't
returned yet because it has 200,000
points and because it still shouldn't be
that slow okay that's what it is using
in the first example there in the docs
well maybe I used a slightly different
and you've used geo zoom level of 10 and
things like that yeah so it may have
down sampled the points but but by the
way you don't need that geo bounding box
then the thing that I used with geo
range is a can more convenient way to do
that you saw that right right yeah okay
okay but so now my question would be as
it as we wait for this okay so fine so
you have successfully used the Geo
position triples for this is this even
though I didn't see that in the
documentation what is the input form
I see location value okay so then an
alternative to that is
gyeo possession which is a 3d location
scroll down a little bit yeah I see well
know that it's actually even further
down okay what on earth is this
alright I don't notice down the siddle
what's green what's yellow I mean so so
green is gonna be some sort of park
simply it doesn't feel it doesn't feel
between the contours here it just draws
two contours contrite so if you if you
did you know Geographic with that same
you know around Mount Everest with the
same range yeah yeah the colors should
match up with that I know I have to
delete some things okay okay okay all
right fine but now what if I wanted to
so if I do a dear geo density plot on
this then what's it gonna do is they're
gonna superimpose some kind of color
layer on top of the green - elevation in
that case okay which I don't think is
you know gonna be the most interesting
or a beautiful thing but okay
okay that's cool all right so fine so
that this I understand what Geo contour
plot is do now what if I want to fill in
and contours contour shading yep okay
does it actually look decent and do you
have decent settings for that
I don't remember it's probably still
using the default color function
I suspect that'll be wrong and
especially if it's gonna superimpose on
the base map right I mean so so probably
we should at least switch it over to
what you know geo smooth histogram and
geo region value plot use sort of a
light to darker like this yellow to
darker Brown sort of thing is I think
what we've come up with as being the
best contrast for our typical base maps
you bring the Geo density plots doesn't
be notebook to the front just I want to
see what the dimensions on the to your
position there are say 11,000 points
very different number yes okay all right
so okay so the thing we were discussing
okay so it sounds like we're not yet
ready to iterate we'll wait for this
we're not yet ready to iterate on the
colors for the vector plots here um
because you're gonna do some work on
that before before we want Jeremy
involved in that I think right um
density plot finished looks like see hmm
okay so it's going in it's it's kind of
orange
orange tinge on top of the base map
correct so now it could be worse
okay any comments from design folk here
Jeremy Tim oh okay all right
it's hard to have a real opinion without
seeing more samples so that's you know
I'd like to see lots of cases before
really chiming in fine cuz we went
through a lot of cases when we were
coming up with those Quebec color weird
color this color orange color yeah yeah
I think we're gonna have renamed it I
mean some I mean we can have a plot
theme which affects both the Geographics
do we have plot themes affecting
Geographics yet the G of this functions
yes Geographics no okay because that's
shitty coming soon now that we have the
new geo silver thankfully in place we
should be able to do that that's my
understanding at least Jeremy have you
been involved in that yet of modernizing
our Geographics colors no okay so I
think that's a coming it's coming story
um okay let's see where did I put the
help over here okay let's keep going
here we're out of time already so the
next group
well context lots complex Wow
what the heck do you do with that
complex vector plot so what does that
mean that means complex vectors of
complex numbers you view a number as a
vector yeah what about vectors of
complex numbers do mean a list version
or something those colors are Glee yes
sorry those are Glee sure so so I see so
this is a complex number plotted as a
vector as opposed to a vector plot which
is a vector field plotted with vectors
so this is viewing the complex number as
defining a vector in complex I mean it
is I mean that's what it is sorry I know
I know but there's another meaning that
that could have which is a complex
vector plot could mean the
four-dimensional thing of you know a
pair of complex numbers in a in a in a
in a pair vector right see - yes yeah
that's usually called complex maps you
know when you want to see you know at
that point that's true yeah so that's a
complex map plot effectively something
like a you know when you have a
conformal map or something right yeah we
have no capability to deal with that
from a visualization point of view right
now right well direct well parametric
plot effectively does it and but we
don't have an easy you know that shows
you a pair that shows the mapping really
yeah that's very amusing I mean talking
of conformal mapping this is highly
relevant complex region plot is highly
relevant to that how do we make a
Joukowsky airfoil yeah it's down there
somewhere I think it is down there
somewhere so by the way I wrote this
function it was in for two first time so
you know
if you get down to applications it
should have the airfoil doesn't it no
airfoil here um if it was an extra plot
one well I write it doesn't matter but
but okay so then wait a minute what's
what's complex contour plot the same
thing with I don't understand how that
because there's not a there's not a
vector it could be the ABS that's what
defines the contours the heck is that
alright that's that that is a real
function right that's the ABS of this is
real function but what if they what if
the values are complex then there are
contours what do you mean they aren't
contour so it has to be real valued from
there typically a point if Z is equal to
a constant then it's either at a point
or it's the whole plane if it's analytic
you know yes sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry
so f of Z in this case what we're
plotting is an f of Z which is a real
number
yeah then you're plotting the contours
in the complex plane of the values of
that real number but what I'm asking is
if f of Z is a complex function is is
maps complex to complex yeah have any
way to plot it right but but if you
that function you know f of Z equals to
Z knots or W or something
well f of Z equals Z squared let's say
something very simple just little caps
every function every complex number z 2z
squared right well what's the inverse
image of you know a constant let's say 1
plus I Z squared equals to 1 plus I
what's the inverse image of that well
maybe more than one but I mean why do we
care about the inverse image because
it's mostly going to be a point or a few
points because this is this is what
contours what's right okay so if you
have an analytic function yes right you
know there's this theorem and complex
analysis that says that if something is
true on the real line and it's analytic
then you can extend it to the whole
plane yeah right and so sine squared
plus cosine squared equals 1 you proved
on the real line and then it's true
everywhere in the complex plane a
consequence of this is that if a
function is constant on the real line
then it's constant in the entire plane
and so there's this is a story of both
analytic continuation on things like
Koshu riemann equations is that true
well whatever it does
I know that results oh right but the
consequence of that is that if you have
an analytic function equal to a constant
then it's either going to be a point or
it's gonna be the whole plane there's
sort of no curve case okay
but this function
so your basic claim is if f of Z is a
complex returns complex numbers then
there's nothing interesting to it can't
do anything interesting correct
okay that's unobvious to me it's an
interesting math claim I mean certainly
something in your possible issue section
here is what is this okay that's
independently plotting the real and
imaginary parts as contours right I mean
that's very traditional Yankee MD type
representation sure mmm now why is it I
mean that would be an obvious default to
take if you give a complex function to
plot that it is effectively re you know
I mean cuz because there is a REM you
know we could say we M of that okay so
let me just understand here so if I were
to do the following thing let me just
try this um if I were to say REM bessel
J zero comma Z splob what went wrong
seems wrong to me doesn't mean that that
that is gonna return a pair right I
don't see why it shouldn't
can you wrap a value weight around that
I'm just curious if it changes anything
I don't think it does and I think this
is a case that Roger and I were
discussing was it late last week on top
lot - in the case of two functions like
that if I say contour plot of let's say
I don't know I mean ream of vessel j0 x
plus iy or fine and it does the same
thing what is that
so wondered wait so I understand the law
is it doing something special I am
curious so do ad equals to zero to both
of those but I'm gonna give this the
zero point I mean it's gonna give this
the zero contour right
does that not have a zero or is it a
lazy little flash no no no that's a
point no no no look that's a row right
okay right and so contour plot when you
give it a list it assumes that it's
always going to be the equation of form
okay
[Music]
well how do I get multiple contour
multiple things plotted on one on one
I guess I just did that with equations
here but if I wanted it not equational
then in the superposition doesn't make
you're claiming the superposition
doesn't make sense could just fill the
whole plane I think we did it
we made that choice back then but when
could say there also that if you're
gonna have several of them one could
sort of say that contour shading is
automatic anyway so it shouldn't do
anything that's a automatic behavior if
you have multiple people sets of
multiple contour iso levels but then we
need to define a style that they all
style differently kind of what was
achieved with show in the other case but
i think that yeah i understand but i
mean you're having redden having
different contour colors of contour
lines which is what it's doing and out
fifteen there as well yes i agree it
just doesn't do it for the multi contour
case right and so i think it what's you
know to certainly simplify those red and
blue plots coming out of complex contour
plots and then some and that would then
presumably also flow backward into right
contour plot the question that i have is
if you find that the function f of z in
the first argument of complex contour
plots is real then that's absolutely
fine then you know then there's a
trivial contour plot if it's always real
then the complex then the imaginary
contour plot is trivial if what you did
was just say we're gonna take the re and
m parts of f of z and we're going to do
differently colored contour lines for
the re parts and the impart then you
would have something there as opposed to
in other words you know i think we need
to solve the problem of multiple contour
shading of superimposing two things with
contour shading which I bet we could do
because if we could do that then all we
have to do for complex contour plots
it's just do that just say if it's
imagine if it's complex then you do the
one for the real part you do the one for
the imaginary part you
to propose them I mean we did solve it
in complex plot how is it solved so
you're saying if I say complex plot um
if you have to pick the right color
function that shows no but let's say I
do this say it says the area AI of Z and
I say you know Z goes from mine I take
that back no no I don't think it doesn't
mean no no no not for multiple functions
sorry no it doesn't complain about data
sets but okay so that's a different
separate issue why is this so slow okay
that's cool okay but so you're saying it
doesn't superimpose it's it's a one
function deal right I mean do cachi
rates that area but it will depending on
which color function you pick it will
make the magnitude and this one what it
shows to face right now it's a little
bit of magnitude you see it another
little bit yeah I just think this color
map is really really bad sure I don't
like it anymore I know that Jeremy or
Tim has a comment on this I I know
personally I'm beginning to get tired
about pure blue I think we should liven
up to the default well white let's so
exactly what we predicted when we did
both themes it's like this is gonna need
a revamp every now and then yeah I
notice it's just every few years right
world changes um by the way on our live
stream there's some questions here that
um Karl is asking be great to see better
geo TIF support anybody want to comment
on that house I do are you aware of
what's happening with your turf we are
working on updating digital library
which handles their reading of formats
so we expect these to be better okay
and in 12.1 I'm not sure taught by one
but if not then the next question for
sure okay
Sandra's suggesting we need a black and
white base map in the case yeah I agree
that that would look a lot better if
we're gonna have coloring on top of the
base map that having a black and white
base map would make more sense
I mean it's gonna look totally weird
with you know the orange is not gonna
mix well with with random you know
freeways which happen to be an orange as
well um it's uh um
Epson dark mode like base maps that look
really good too with color a little bit
of that with no plot theme goes to
marketing in the G of his plots yes oh
man that is horrendous sander is
pointing out what a horrendous fact do
you see that he's pointing out that
orange and blue are switched around and
these is on purpose I know what do you
mean it's on purpose okay explain I mean
it looks nice with the orange one and
the bottom thing looks nice with orange
I mean so one of the considerations in
that is that you know so if you are say
combining plot with histogram or you
know a list flat with a bar chart or
something yes that the curves and the
reasonable
I mean argument restive actually used
the same colors as a flip around that
would have been better to shift the
color sequence or something
yes um sander is complaining that it
really becomes confusing but I think we
should look at that that's a really good
point I you know I think we should
consider just using different slightly
different color palettes here to avoid
this flip around thing if you mean just
a darker version of yellow and blue for
the curves I believe we had that at one
point and soval sh complained that there
wasn't enough contrast when he can put
you know a PDF curve on top of a
histogram okay
I claim this should be looked at again I
claim this is goofy I mean in other
words
we will be better off not ever having a
blue in here if we went from orange to
some completely different color here
and never went through blue we'd be
better off that'd be very Halloweeny
well it depends what the color is I mean
I like the blue with the orange it goes
very nicely but I this point is crazy
well I mean so on the other hand the
other thing is is that there's also some
consideration of what do we like for
what percentage of the time right you
know so 80% of 3d plots are one surface
no I understand we like what it is for
one surface there's no problem with one
surface okay right but I'm saying that
you know each additional surface is a
lower percentage of the cases I
understand that this is crazy okay we
should just pick you know color space is
big we don't have to have colors that
agree but flip around
see what I'm saying I mean it just
doesn't make any sense I'm sure if we go
to Forex okay if we go heretofore okay
that's just weird
right it's just weird to have those
first two flipped around surely we can
do something about that I don't know
what the right thing to do is but we can
do something about it
okay listen logistically I am really
supposed to go to another meeting here
but I know we're going to come back to
this one um
[Music]
um we need to finish off this one and
then we've got other ones to do so I
suggest what we do after this when I
come back from this next meeting is we
do because I know we've got to finish a
bunch of these design reviews today so
Roger we should just have a rolling
design of you saying where we bring in
the different people who are involved in
the different design reviews that we're
trying to do okay so we can we can live
stream it is anybody paying attention
here can we figure this out please do I
have to go through the logistics for
this no we'll take care of it thank you
um okay so I'll be back here with
everybody um soon and I encourage people
on the live stream can we should be back
so I think we should continue this one
to just see whether we can just finish
this one and then then we'll go into
graphs and networks and so on okay and
I'm gonna completely skip that outside
meeting okay
all right thank you all very much see
you soon see